last time you're on the show I remember
this very clearly I met your parents
yeah afterwards and your dad is a
character loved your dad but he's a
character okay so I got to ask how's he
doing he's great he says hello oh good
see with your new gayness yeah he's
gonna love her he's great he did ask me
a few weeks ago my dad called me and
asked me to explain to him over the
phone how to download and use uber which
I don't know if you guys have ever had
to help your parents with technology but
it's kind of a most efficient way to
kill your human spirit yeah yeah he
called me he's like Nassim I'm going to
the airport right now can you teach me
uber and I should have just been like I
love you but absolutely not
and I wrote down what he said these were
this is this is exactly the text that
you got from him in this order d no this
is a conversation yeah I wrote it down
for the next half hour these were the
questions my father my father asked me
I'll just read them to you how how do
you download an app there's an Apple
Store on my phone where what do you mean
on the screen of my phone okay I'm in
how do I know my password do you know it
why don't you know it
now what how does the uber driver know
to pick me up can you see me who is he
do I text him first or does he text me
oh he's not on his way yet because I
have to open an account first how how do
I do that what do you mean what does the
screen say what do you mean what do I
mean okay should I do this software
update real quick a screen what what the
heck is a screen grab how how do I take
one how what how what what what how hold
down what at the same time which button
how and literally for the next five
minutes I tried explaining to him how to
take a screen grab which then devolved
into a mind-blowing conversation about
what a button is and I'm not a violent
person but in that moment I at least
understood like the impulse for murder
suicide yeah yeah the best was a week
later I see him and he's like guess who
finally figured out over and he shows me
his email and it says thank you for
signing up for uber here's a copy of the
employee handbook
[Laughter]
I have begged my dad many times to get
uber because he always needs a ride to
go someplace I'm like get uber you know
I'll set you up on uber you please and I
said like it's on me you know please get
uber and he won't do it cuz he's like
that stubborn generation of like oh no
no but then he'll say things like yeah I
might you said the other day I gotta go
to New Hampshire to a medical conference
oh maybe I'll take uber I'm like no
Hooper's not taking hit in New Hampshire
it's not a magic carpet
you